hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 ok we just climbed a mountain
mine Norton was pointing a gun at uh I'm
sorry they're supposed to make it okay
you never believed in me for this
mission or us I think you'll find
someone else to help me and now he's
dead
pepper touched it just like everything
else what's that supposed to be is that
what you really think
yeah before you here at gunpoint I guess
that's what it took
oh yeah because someone put a gun to my
head well not in bed because someone put
one to piss oh come on Ellie
I had no chassis boo you blow my head
off you'd be like Oh Norton it's okay I
didn't care about that Isaak guy nah
hello what is this Oh a tiny itty-bitty
ladder oh man I'm so glad this emergency
ladder is here I would have been lost
otherwise I just climbed up the sheer
face of a mountain that would have
really thrown me oh boy
what who's over there who be banging
hello frozen buddy oh good thing you
didn't get turned into Necromorph Roth I
have to shoot you but for now I only
have to shoot whatever's making noise
over here
hello what hi
oh I get it
that's weird hey the black ones are
starting to come out and play
oh thank you for dying ah
hi Jacob I'm Dinah fire I'm okay okay
hey buddy
ah they're everywhere Jesus this tiny
ladder was a trap was all a trap well
Swan some haha
Jesus I heard some did not see some I
hear him hear him all over the place
there was nobody there
eventually talking are they same words
and stuff
fire quick oh it's out of ammo my bad
boom
Oh give me this please you still live
over there brew you good
I'd have to a put to hurt none yeah
Isaac Clark don't mess no [ __ ] from
nobody
hey way Weller's compact frame who was
Weller I know who a man was but Weller
is unknown to me and my scavenge e-bot
is waiting for me back at the bench so I
need to make my way there as soon as
possible my guns oh okay here we go
Ellie's got to be okay with me me and
her boobs will be together I mean - me
and her will be be together once again
guys I found a cargo cage but it's
wedged into the clip I'll try to free
the sitting-down okay Jeremy
come on Ellie you're new
no ace moobs la da nija find lift
controls ah okay yes so finally they're
on the receiving end of awaiting for the
elevator kind of thing first check to
see if there's a behind me
then um appears to be stuck
gimme oh that's your leg I really kill
you just like that two shots is all it
takes bro
suck it down ah Jesus stop that
yo [ __ ] hiding out in the snow
hey few shots that's all it took hi
let's see you ah baloney ah what the
hell
bloody hell Jesus
hey come from behind me and then I
forget about the ones in front of me no
I think not
thank you kindly for now I heard you son
of a [ __ ] go come on give me something
I don't want just uh ha oh you go get it
now hey he's got it good okay that is
not what is that there we go scrap metal
or something or whatever it was I don't
really know don't care it was stuff and
I got it cuz I can oh yeah I'm trying to
save my friends oh yeah
gotta save Ellie's boobs I mean Ellie
Ghana god save oh I'm going up again
this is good who would put the lift
controls so far away from the actual
lift wait what mo support that sounds
like I need that
dammit I've got too many med kits so
many med kits
dholu Isaac
swings wrong everything's here
mama ski jump
okay don't jump jump a crowd jump around
hey hi I said wash key now we go up hey
seven a little Necromorph I see up there
it is it's ready to die thank you for
doing something I don't know it out of
there man God Lana
Boosh oh oh come on really Isaac you
can't jump bye Josh
there we go that is professional I see
that there are little icicles falling
down on me as well something's behind me
but I can't exactly see it just got to
keep going forward I will be fine see
we're fine we're okay we drove it off
don't
trouble kept cushion to go home
but matches Robert understood that nope
I'm here for you I mean that yeah there
we go now it's your starting to see the
truth
I mean Carver was there he's backed me
up on it I mean he was under the guys
command and he could tell that he was
gone cuckoo bonkers crazy but this
detectives ecology scavenging salvaging
scavenging scavenging and salvaging is
now scavenging I've gone this way
because the bright blue light on my hand
and in my brain tells me to another
frozen body all right moving forward one
step closer to reuniting with the marker
I mean how these moves I mean where's
your big orange ball go now try the
Kinesis something that was not there
crazy about to die about to die man
today nine son of a [ __ ] oh god I'm
done I did it again what am I like Stu I
my aim is so good that I instantly like
your yellow pen then that's how good I
am at this game that's it that's
justified with that you're too good at
the game that's why you suck at it
that's why duh why's it card doesn't
suck at anything okay okay let's just
calm down here Dyan calm do not come I'm
calm
go this way way no once it was over here
secrets and the darkness ah artifact
ruin us something else I don't know what
it was
another scavenging bot I got another
belly okay I found on the left point
there's still no which you guys
right so far we just hit the cage it's a
festive pretty bad up here hope I find a
wig be careful I don't need to lose both
you and Robert in the same day oh oh man
I had a lot of stuff and a scavenging
button now get three scavenging bites
and I got more stuff than I know what to
do with gay resource deposited get a
craft cert weapon can craft weapon
upgrades I'm curious about that isn't
there a way to craft them I have no idea
anyway I got more attachments here so
let's some and they're all for support
for a partner which I do not have ammo
sweeper that would be I don't have a
tungsten I need tungsten I need lots of
tungsten how whatever I'm good let's
just carry on weed weed weed weed okay
moving forward rocket launcher no
probably not good to use on a mountain
side cause avalanches and whatnot it
awfully is convenient that there are
these two winches placed every so often
right when I need him whoever was the
previous expedition leaders were very
good and a student knowing that I would
need them what oh hello
huh there we go
oh not good jaysus hahaha
how does that work
hey what are you doing trying to kill me
Jesus get out of here with that noise
come on now
okay yeah aah what happened my head
grazed it and that killed me
Oh baloney oh that's I'm going up this
side no nice touch
aah horse hockey I forgot I call a
mulligan that well yeah Wow so great
movie go I don't need a way stasis on
that first one unless I keep falling
like a loser maybe I do
just oh come on Isaac really really
uh-oh really Isaac really they're not
gonna
what the hell Isaac seriously you're
making me look bad on the Internet
you know how important my internet
reputation is aa Li Jie's what was I
doing wrong
both in the right position wasn't I
how you stop it you you stop okay haha
okay what I don't even that doesn't even
make sense
you you shut up and you I'm gonna stasis
the piss out of you
guess you oh well whatever this is bull
this is bull this is textbook definition
of bull like I'm not bad at games I'm
just driving to trump down can I go up
here knocking on mirror gardels a good
jump Isaac good job there way to not
suck
thank you thank you marklar oh look I've
worked out for the better your shop
stupid icebergs
or where we are guitar burger or grain
my wife ah - I'm gonna buy ah ah ah this
is so bad this is so bad so so so chunko
chunko bad half bad Rob Robin um around
my shop
grammar her I think it lurks works
better if I look yeah
oh that did not work out better nice job
all right guys come on a see right there
yeah that does it yeah it's the stuff
that's the money right there no j-just
okay now I'm gonna Haro Oh bull hockey
get over there your dick you
[ __ ]
I knew oh you what I can't quite there
we go alright now we're making bacon Wow
okay all right get a Isaac hold your
[ __ ] together you're not out of water
yet there's still time to fail duh by
the car don't fail I the car to fail now
you're such a dick Isaac sometimes I
just wish the marker had killed you you
drove out of our gallery David the
lockers taking over my mind
my buddy please don't
No thank you no thank you no thank you
no thank you
I would rather not have any please then
thank you proton thank you very much but
no I do not require anything from you
hey big behind me all right we seem good
open for checkout you get to get to get
you get if you loot the bodies burn the
bodies stomp the bodies
oh look it's another miniscule little
ladder here how useful oh that's even
the point why couldn't the developers
just make a ram
I found the winch I'm gonna start it up
yeah good dad hey go into something wait
I don't like this just talk to me don't
look down what's our next step
now know that in order to turn off the
machine will need some sort of key of
course the researcher called it the
codec okay
so whereas we have to make one how do we
do that the same way they did 200 years
ago that belief it just blown a fuse
maybe I can divert power from the lights
okay how do I do that
shoot the lights up nope that would have
been my logical engineer guess what
well uh maybe I could just use my
massive muscles what am I doing here
what am i doing oh maybe by diverting
power from the light they mean know what
oh yeah
shooting out it does not work I know not
how to do this alright whatever oh I see
I see I see over here over here over
here duh okay if I mess this up so tell
me about this rosetta yeah we don't know
much just that the codex was made from
her research well only find it in the
facility at the top of this month great
see almost oh hey first try baby haha
did I do it did that do it or what I
have to start it back up again
yeah ah here we go use my muscles take
off my helmet for some reason
dude oh yeah
good joke ah see that wasn't so bad not
bad I was crying the whole way just get
me some solid ground under my
karma
No
uncle facedown us with it I can reach
her just tailor to the winch Santos eyes
it's too late for that
cut Tim hi Hannah it was gonna take us
all down with it come on damn it kid I
promised her let's get a drink sir
another step
I think she's got belly
Isaac was pulling the whole cliff down
you couldn't have saved her
can you get back up here yeah I think
there's a way up another side all right
holy hell poor lady she was terrified
out of her mind she didn't deserve that
was that off line up whoa hi hey buddy
welcome back to the funhouse you ready
to play I bet you is I know you don't
you still hit me I let you hit me
oh what's that I'm gonna miss you with
that too Hey look they come flying I
mean boom thank you goodbye
these little guys I need to take care of
them ah hit you good water there spice
cuz I'm a Kinesis master barely boom ah
this I turn my back for one
hey how about you get the [ __ ] off me
huh how about dad
pika garbage stupid dick huh boom I said
you - boom
that's more better
looks like my scavenger BOTS is ready oh
no you don't get me a shot give me a
shot baby ah two of them gone Hey oh
don't hit me twice your hemi price
you're an a-hole there we go
no you shut up I learned how to side
straight that's what I do what are you
gonna do ah get away from me how's that
still there I've been shooting that
right one for ages now come on Josh ah
damn time there we go
there we go
this where I actually finish this guy
off this guy just gonna run away like a
little baby again I swear it's that one
on the right
oh it's gonna be trouble
yeah go crying home to mama no way where
where where are you think you're going
yeah you kids free girl on the top ones
a guy son of a [ __ ]
Oh what this air hole deserves to die
I keep hitting it but not where I need
to
try there we go finally papi
huh come on Jesus man
you don't have any orange left to shoot
Oh
Sabri crying those getting very old now
there we go
come on aah
cuckoo boy where you going up oh my god
you gotta stop this
aah aah what the tits
they're just getting ridiculous now
and again wait is there something was I
supposed to be doing something if I was
supposed to be doing something else I
would I'm going to be so pissed there's
got to be something else that I needed
to do that was totally not explained to
me oh my god you got to be kidding me
ah
come on okay what am I looking at oh I
see it god damn it now I see it holy
hell there's a freaking harpoon up there
that's a freakin our poon over there
oh how do I get them going ah [ __ ] you
I'm out of med kits holy balls how do I
get this going oh I see
come on guys [ __ ] I'm out of med kits
now thank you very much try to lure into
those tracking lasers okay yeah yeah
that would have been great to know a
while ago Jesus balls I wasted so much
ammo on this [ __ ]
they did a piss-poor job of explaining
that one thank you he's gonna quit free
okay cable available oh this come on
ah hi your douche
oh god I can't spam f my Wow days are
not with me again there we go
that hurt I heard a lot okay man I
wasted so much ammo and health packs on
this dick I just gonna give me a friggin
parts box why didn't they tell me did
they tell me if they did they didn't
tell me very well oh whatever
whatever you know what what I killed him
that's all that matters
Lodi frickin da could have been like a
you know a reminder like I think they
might have said something about some
winch I don't know they said something
in the beginning but well [ __ ] me then
I'm they said something that could have
been like hey get that winch your
harpoon thing working I don't know that
could have been done better that could
have been done better
I have criticisms and legitimate
criticisms about that fight
Hey
you're a good man Isaac
everything you could
no I didn't I gave up belly
I'm so sorry
must be the place
how the hell do we find this from Santa
she must have a lab up there someplace
we should look for an office or a set of
files anything with her name on it we
can take that to the entrance come on
oh yeah things are heating up between me
and Ally here all right chapter 14 we
are rushing through at a breakneck pace
only five chapters remain be a good one
to dab llege one rate of fire hell's to
the yeah all right so anyway since some
progress chapters have been saving very
sequentially I whenever i stop an
episode I have to track backtrack to the
place if I or go forward or backwards
depending on where I was so I am going
to stop it here since it's a convenient
place to stop it so thank you everybody
so much for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
ah
door
Oh
love